they'd rather have no job than work for
this woke snob yeah the vp staffers are
in short supply as another one says
goodbye
they're jumping from the nearest terrace
to escape their boss kamala kamala
harris whatever the vp lost her
speechwriter
but the bigger news is she had a
speechwriter
that's like being michael moore's
personal trainer
a white house official tells fox that
kate childs graham is quote leaving the
office but not the family at the end of
the month the family she's really making
the government sound like what it is a
bunch of mobsters swindling your tax
dollars so she's not working but she has
a family reminds me of pete buda judge
that makes her the eighth kamala staffer
to resign since the veep took office if
she loses one more employee she'll have
enough stamps on her make nine employees
quit get one free card
who knows maybe her annoying laugh will
quit next
but maybe it doesn't matter that the
speechwriter quit she's so good on the
fly
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
let anybody
suggest to you that you are what they
think you should be
you tell them who you are and who you
know you are than what you intend to be
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no kinko's
there's no office max near them
with us in government
we campaign with the plan
uppercase t uppercase p v plan
oh i tell kamala what we wanted to know
but i wonder if she's just laughing our
faces
[Laughter]
what do you want to know
i want to give you i want to give you
the opportunity so adorable cat i'm
worried that her speeches will suffer
now that their speechwriter is left yeah
i mean it's a weird time for the
speechwriter to quit because like she
doesn't really do that yeah right like
she doesn't really give speeches seems
like the easiest job ever you don't do
anything and then every now and then you
just compare stuff to pearl harbor yeah
thank you
yes why would you quit that job exactly
kennedy what if she suddenly becomes
better what if it was a speechwriter's
fault oh wouldn't that be a twist and
veep that we weren't anticipating
yeah what if what if the speechwriter
was actually like purposefully tanking
her like you know really secretly loves
people to judge and is doing whatever
you know this person can to bring kamala
harris down which she's really doing a
great job i i wonder what the gossip is
like what do people talk about in the
office like you know i just talked to
someone from the white house and she is
definitely not on the ticket in 2024. we
got to get out of here yeah this is
spiro agnew on the opposite of steroids
yes yes i love spiro great head of hair
emily you know um what i noticed thank
you
talking about spiro agnew you're no
spiro agnew though you have nice hair
anyway
i forgot my question but i'm gonna come
up with a different one i've noticed
that as incompetent as she is there's
still nobody
mimicking her on any late night show any
comedy show anything she and that she
has tremendous i mean that's a great
buffer that no one's gonna touch you
right well why on all of those late
night talk shows it's just because they
know they'll be called racist exactly
snl too exactly like the reason she's
untouchable is because that's the
culture that has been created by the far
left anyway so it's not as if she is
untouchable it's just that they deem
that she is because they know they're
going to be canceled if they go after a
black woman
and i think to those of us from
california who lived under her
ridiculous reign for so long none of
this surprises us she's never stood for
anything politically we her entire
campaigns and offices have always been
hallmarked by infighting by many civil
wars by the fact that staffers are
frustrated that she wouldn't commit to
policies or anything she would just
capitulate she's the biggest
cheerleader for silicon valley but she
assures victims or she'll be on their
side for cyber crime the list goes on
that i think people were constantly
confused by her they were constantly
intimidated by her and they saw that she
was a weak leader frankly and probably a
jerk at the same time so all of those
fleeing ship like to those of us from
cali we were like yeah it's been
happening for decades tyrus uh
i'd hate to have a boss like that
[Laughter]
he talks a lot yeah yeah you know
i feel bad for the speech writer cause
just imagine i'm pretty sure everything
that was written was not used but every
time the speechwriter would come home be
like you wrote that yeah seriously i
mean excuse me i whipped this out i made
a couple notes yeah and you used my
first one so i won't use it and
unfortunately because i'm on the wrong
side of 40 i got to use these now
uh check this out this is one of my
favorite all-time that that if the
speechwriter
should have resigned after this one
just because they are illegal doesn't
mean they broke the law yeah if i was in
the speech writing room i would have
went i i
that's not what i said who let her watch
chappelle before she went out so
you know and then this one is just
phenomenal it's time for us to do what
we have been doing and that time is
every day yes
i would be
taking drugs after that if i was the
speed writer because you're going to
come home and hear about you wrote this
you wrote this no it wasn't me
so i love you i love the color of your
post-its
what's wrong with that
i just said i love that it's me
gut-filled you got a problem i thought
it was a very lively color i like it
yeah i mean yeah i think
there's two kennedy
oh pink
i have daughters man
up next are you curious if you could
drive like the fast and the furious hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else